[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your house definition and it's time to
break down the best and worst show that
Netflix has ever made that is too hot to
handle released on national horny day
too hot to handle is a dating show of
our time that enforces social distancing
and makes it so that people get in
trouble for coming into contact with one
another
basically the premise is that a number
of rip men and bikini-wearing women that
think for weeks constitutes as a
long-term relationship all get together
on an island in order to win a prize of
$100,000 but there's one proviso in
order to do it they have to keep it in
their pants
every time they kiss have an intimate
moment or accidentally trip and fall
into a vagina their prize money is
reduced way hundred thousand dollars and
all they have to do is not have sex just
get married boom if my wife's watching
this I'm just kidding I'm I'm just okay
I'm just kidding
anyway to what the handle has clearly
collected the sickest most psychotic
nymphomaniacs in the world that would
quite happily ruin their holiday chances
of winning $100,000 and the trust of
their friends just to kiss a guy that
they're actually not deign to actually
know I into him you will hate it within
the first 30 seconds but watch eight
hours of it anyway leave your brain at
home don't think too much because you'll
hurt yourself and sit back and watch it
is you remember how fun summer used to
be before we get into the cast
themselves we have to talk about Lana
aka the third iteration of Skynet after
Lana failed to kill humanity using
terminators she's decided that the only
way to actually stop us is to take away
our ability to breed however even she is
tempting as her name is anal backwards
now firstly we have the villain of the
piece Francesca who is basically all the
crappy people from Mean Girls combined
into one
she enslaves a poor easily led henchman
named Hayley who she tricks into falling
in love with her
so that she can manipulate her once she
serves a purpose she abandoned sir which
makes her leave the holiday of a
lifetime but but it's not like we care
because she sucked anyway Francesca was
Harry and the two kiss which loses their
money and both pin the blame on one
another
this makes francesca and Haley vote for
some reason decide that they will lose
the group more money and thus they kiss
one another I still have no idea what
Haley got out of all of this other than
kissing a really attractive woman with a
perfect bud never mind
at first they managed to cover up this
crime and due to their oscar-worthy
acting will probably clean up at the
awards this year which won't be that
hard right now they get angry at being
accused blame others for their failings
and eventually everyone sees them for
what they really are which is the
greatest love story of all time
throughout the show Francesca
consistently loses the group money and
she's worse for the economy than COBIT
is by the climax of the series I think
she actually loses them about $35,000
but it's not like she needed it for a
boob job anyway now when you're losing
this much money you're gonna stress
people out and no more is this more
apparent than with Kells who back home
is an accountant I feel like this guy
needs to replace the Jordan Peele
sweating meme because every time I see
him he's looking more and more stressed
out it's like he's seeing the pennies
slowly slip away second-by-second whilst
Francesca's vajayjay ends up like a JK
Rowling book why is that because it's
got Harry in it he even turns down a
kiss from Francesca because Scrooge
McDuck is more bothered about the money
than the monopoly man in the end he's
not a bad guy and I know I rinsed on him
a bit but I was quite happy to see him
finally get reunited with his one true
love in the end cash
there's also David who isn't too bad of
a guy either the muscle man pretty much
always ends up second-best because he's
the type of man that can't even make eye
contact with someone without crying
however he genuinely is a nice guy and
if this was the matrix then he would be
fully written in bro code he puts his
friends first namely Sharon before
everyone else he even says when he looks
at Rhonda that he can stare at her
without thinking of sure
which mmm I'm surprised the girls aren't
falling at your feet mate
he also says to run their I stopped
seeing your body which she replies with
no one's ever said that to me before
yeah yeah because because it's a
terrible line love Rhonda and Sharon end
up becoming one of the Power couples of
the group and the two actually build a
meaningful connection with one another
just just a shame or a son who
absolutely hates the guy which coming
from a single-parent household myself
probably means that he's already met 40
other dudes like Sharon also I've never
actually heard of a guy called Sharon
Sharon before except in Greek mythology
in ancient Greece Sharon was the
ferryman that used to escort the souls
of the Damned across the river Styx and
in a way he's probably gonna do the same
with Rhonda and escort her on an endless
life of misery and despair yay
seems like a nice guy though there's
also this school Jim no Connie Connie
yet sorry I don't remember her doing
anything at least she didn't lose their
money I suppose and out of everyone
she's probably one of the only people
that doesn't feel like they're in a show
designed purely to recruit people for
Isis next up is Bryce who since the
death of Michael Jackson has become the
world's best dancer he goes in with his
eyes on the money and his torture on the
honey but after he's told he can't do
anything he takes it worse than finding
out he's in lockdown and the red-light
district is doing four for one Bryce
lives on a boat so he's either really
rich or really poor and he claims to be
an intellectual thinker but also doesn't
know if a clock starts at 12:00 or 1:00
so now I don't know what to believe
he gets attracted to Chloe who though a
complete idiot discovers the word
animosity I actually quite like Chloe
and she goes on a journey of
self-discovery whoo after messing guys
around it gets a taste of her own
medicine she screwed over by a guy named
cauri but it's the same haircut as
Toadstool from Mario he comes in to have
some fun but gets kicked out because
what kind of guy gets both nipples
pierced here comes the dislikes lastly
well I would all of the people that
actually worth talking about is Matthew
who's nicknamed Jesus now by the end of
the show you might actually believe that
he
is in fact Jesus he walks on water tells
tales and fables to the group so it
becomes a cult leader else the Judas and
even ends up dying for the sins of the
group well he leaves early but it's the
same thing
Jesus has a hilarious moment in which he
sort of acts like Kurt Russell them the
thing in order to get to the bottom of
Francesca and Hayley's kiss and I swear
the guy should work for the CIA because
he makes Sherlock Holmes look like mr.
Magoo now after being celibate for all
of an agonizing three hours the group of
gifted watches that light green when
they have the world of green light you
know this stuff isn't highbrow let's be
honest it reminds me of that scene and
Wonder Woman when she says that Steve
let's a little watch tell him what to do
and I've just realized its references
like that why I could easily win a
hundred G's for no sex anyway they
slowly build a deeper connection and as
a reward they're given green lights it
all comes to a head for the final night
in which Harry and Francesca must spend
an entire evening in a private suite
without touching one another this will
allow the hundred thousand prize fund to
be replenished and they will all get a
cut will Fran do it has Harry been
taking self-defense classes well it's
one of the biggest cliffhangers since
you shot junior but they managed to make
it through the group leave with the
prize money and all get very strong yes
that's right very strong Yanni's in the
end Kells avoids having a heart attack
Ronda takes Sharon to meet her son
probably though I can't imagine you'll
set the house of like an home alone and
drop a metal pipe on his head and though
Sharon ended up asking Ronda to be his
girlfriend in the finale the two haven't
really posted anything official on
social media so it is difficult to tell
whether he's still alive or not
Rhonda's son is probably three now so
he's likely the same height as Sharon
and it's probably beat the crap out of
him whether they're together or not we
don't know
but watch this space for more up to
axiom never revisit in this again mirror
miss Fran and Harry haven't updated any
of their social media standings to
reflect whether they're in a
relationship or not I feel so sad
sitting looking this stuff up dear me
they did promise to move in together and
even the album was dropped but who
hasn't said that on holiday when they're
drunk I know I have
anyway we wish them all the best going
forward and one day we can only hope
that we get a relationship like that
couple goals and everything overall too
hard to handle was the worst thing I've
ever seen it was a complete disaster
and I absolutely loved it Netflix are
killing it with the dating shows right
now and hopefully it's not too long
before they do a show that's too hot to
handle because as we know love is blind
so great jokes should you watch this
well it's not like you're doing anything
else is it you had time to watch this
crap video so yeah you're not exactly
busy right now are you yeah anyway yeah
don't don't forget to like the video
please now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on too hard to handle so
drop them below in the comments to show
me your thoughts if you enjoyed this
video wants something else that's a bit
more lighthearted
then make sure you check out our review
of Tiger King which is gonna be linked
at the end we go over the best slash
worst aspects of that show and discuss
what happened to everyone after it you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month and please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this is
Monty come when the Marvel phase 3 pot 1
box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications own more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of May and the cell be shipped
down from then to ever gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so and that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking time to watch this you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]